Caption: alrighty we've
Caption: pretty much officially filled out
Caption: Jakarta goal uh here today
Caption: um next up I'm pleased to introduce Todd
Caption: Becker uh who will be talking about
Caption: distributed databases why what and how
Caption: so please make him welcome
Caption: thanks hi I'm Todd
Caption: I'm a principal software engineer at
Caption: Family Zone which is a local Perth based
Caption: company in the field of cyber safety for
Caption: children
Caption: and so first I'd like to thank the
Caption: sponsors of DG Perth 2022 I'm grateful
Caption: to be up here to speak to you today
Caption: I'm going to be talking about
Caption: distributed databases
Caption: and first the distributed database
Caption: refers to a database that just uses more
Caption: than one network computer or a cluster
Caption: of computers this allows them to scale
Caption: up to handle more work and more data
Caption: than a single computer can do but why
Caption: why talk about this well the amount of
Caption: data that's been collected and managed
Caption: has grown immensely over the past couple
Caption: of decades the rise of the internet and
Caption: the proliferation of devices in that
Caption: time has driven the development of more
Caption: advanced software to handle that data
Caption: but as Tech professionals we don't often
Caption: need to actually use this kind of
Caption: database system and the majority of
Caption: software just works well with a
Caption: traditional relational database
Caption: but if we do use a distributed database
Caption: we may not truly understand how it works
Caption: or what its strengths and weaknesses are
Caption: and how to use it most effectively
Caption: so distributed databases however are a
Caption: vast and complex subject and my short
Caption: talk can only barely skim the surface
Caption: my aim is to give you a little
Caption: understanding of some of the concepts
Caption: which may help evaluate a distributed
Caption: database for solving your problem
Caption: relational databases have been around
Caption: since the mid 1970s and this model has
Caption: proven incredibly flexible and useful
Caption: for solving any number of problems and
Caption: in my opinion this Tech has been a
Caption: Cornerstone of why software now runs
Caption: much of the world
Caption: a crucial feature of these databases
Caption: isn't apparent in the name and that's
Caption: acid transactions I won't go through the
Caption: full definitions right now but to
Caption: paraphrase these properties provide
Caption: guarantees on the correctness and
Caption: reliability of your data and they
Caption: prevent transactions from interfering
Caption: with each other
Caption: structured query language or SQL was
Caption: also invented at the end of the 1970s to
Caption: make good use of relational databases
Caption: and still very popular today
Caption: so these DBS dominated the landscape for
Caption: 40 years and are still prevalent today
Caption: however towards the turn of the century
Caption: people started to find that they were
Caption: needing more and more powerful systems
Caption: they were reading sorry they were
Caption: reaching the limit of how much computing
Caption: power they could throw at any particular
Caption: data set
Caption: but data was still being produced at an
Caption: increasing rate
Caption: so some vendors did produce large
Caption: specialized computers like mainframes
Caption: but they're extremely expensive and they
Caption: require that big upfront investment for
Caption: your Peak capacity
Caption: but some of the big companies that we
Caption: know today like Google and Amazon were
Caption: just just starting to experience their
Caption: rise so they needed to find ways to
Caption: scale up in a big way to cope with their
Caption: new demand
Caption: they didn't want to use expensive
Caption: specialized Hardware if they were going
Caption: to scale they would need to do do it
Caption: with the commodity Hardware that was
Caption: readily available
Caption: so as the saying goes necessity is the
Caption: mother of invention
Caption: and the needs of these first internet
Caption: scale companies led to innovation in
Caption: this area and new systems were built
Caption: that could share the load across many
Caption: computers
Caption: so a wave of new databases appeared to
Caption: help solve the problem
Caption: in 2006 and 2007 Google published the
Caption: big table paper and Amazon published the
Caption: Dynamo paper
Caption: and these seminal papers ceded the
Caption: generation of new systems that were
Caption: inspired by them they were pushing the
Caption: boundaries of what was possible at the
Caption: time
Caption: most importantly they were very scalable
Caption: they all had some things in common they
Caption: didn't use SQL for reading and writing
Caption: data and they didn't use the relational
Caption: model at all
Caption: there were lots of different approaches
Caption: to modeling the data each originally
Caption: targeted at solving a specific problem
Caption: so for example key value databases graph
Caption: wide column and document Etc
Caption: in the era of the purpose-built data
Caption: store had begun
Caption: choose to suit your specific need rather
Caption: than a one-size-fits-all approach
Caption: the data modeling is denormalized and
Caption: flexible some were optimized for very
Caption: right heavy workloads some are optimized
Caption: for read heavy workloads
Caption: and this shift away from the relational
Caption: model and from SQL led to the term no
Caption: SQL being coined to emphasize that
Caption: they're not an SQL or not only SQL
Caption: systems
Caption: but they had real limitations as well
Caption: they didn't support asset transactions
Caption: generally and they did not replace
Caption: relational databases and some of the
Caption: reasons for that why I'll cover
Caption: computer scientists were a little ahead
Caption: of this need so in 1999 Eric Brewer
Caption: published the cap principle which became
Caption: the cap theorem and I mentioned it
Caption: because the cap theorem has heavily
Caption: influenced the design of many
Caption: distributed data stores since that time
Caption: it says that any distributed data store
Caption: can only provide two of the following
Caption: three guarantees consistency
Caption: availability and partition tolerance
Caption: now consistency we're familiar with from
Caption: asset transactions
Caption: partition tolerance and availability are
Caption: Concepts that only exist in distributed
Caption: systems with multiple separate computers
Caption: a CP system is one that gives up
Caption: availability to guarantee consistency if
Caption: you write value a all subsequent reads
Caption: will read value a
Caption: if there's a network problem it may
Caption: prevent you from writing or writing data
Caption: that if it might cause problems later
Caption: an AP system is one that gives up
Caption: consistency to be available you'll
Caption: always get an answer even if the data
Caption: could be stale
Caption: and if there's a network problem it'll
Caption: accept your rights and reads even if
Caption: there's a chance for it to be lost later
Caption: or even stale
Caption: theoretically a CA system would give up
Caption: neither but it's generally considered
Caption: infeasible
Caption: this way of thinking became the de facto
Caption: way to categorize these distributed
Caption: databases because it answers the
Caption: important question if something starts
Caption: to fail can I align the database to say
Caption: consistent no matter what
Caption: or can I rely on the database to stay
Caption: available as much as I can
Caption: before distributed databases people are
Caption: already dealing with scale problems with
Caption: the concept of partitioning which you
Caption: may have heard of
Caption: partitioning is the name for just
Caption: splitting up a data set into smaller
Caption: subsets or pieces and this is for
Caption: improved performance or easier
Caption: management of the data
Caption: for petitioning to work there needs to
Caption: be a way of deciding where a particular
Caption: piece of data belongs and this is
Caption: usually done by taking a key from your
Caption: data and this is called the partition
Caption: key and the choice of partition key can
Caption: be crucial in determining the
Caption: performance of your workload
Caption: partitioning using a Time Field is a
Caption: good choice for data sets to continually
Caption: grow over time
Caption: by petitioning where the range of time
Caption: means that one partition can't grow
Caption: forever and if you need to prune off the
Caption: oldest times you can just drop the
Caption: oldest partitions
Caption: but for petitioning a regular string key
Caption: and imagine in this example that your
Caption: keys only start with the 26 letters of
Caption: the English alphabet if you wanted to
Caption: split this into three partitions you
Caption: could just simply take a to G for
Caption: petition 1 HTTP for partition 2 and Q to
Caption: Z for partition 3.
Caption: hash partitioning is another common type
Caption: where a hash function is used applied to
Caption: the key and the result is used to work
Caption: out what partitioned to use
Caption: this is similar to how hash table works
Caption: which you've probably come across but
Caption: good hash functions are excellent at
Caption: spreading your keys across out across
Caption: any range even if you have keys that are
Caption: very similar which might not have worked
Caption: in the alphabetical example
Caption: for a distributed database to spread the
Caption: load across multiple computers clearly
Caption: you need to spread the data across these
Caption: computers or nodes as well if each node
Caption: had a full copy of the data it would
Caption: limit the size of your database somewhat
Caption: defeating the purpose
Caption: so what makes sense is divide the
Caption: divider sorry is to divide the data up
Caption: and share it across those multiple
Caption: computers
Caption: this sounds like partitioning well it is
Caption: there's also another name for this
Caption: sharding
Caption: they're often used interchangeably but
Caption: strictly sharding is partitioning data
Caption: across multiple computers or multiple
Caption: database instances
Caption: a common sharding technique is known as
Caption: consistent hashing
Caption: and this type of house partitioning is
Caption: designed to avoid an awkward scaling
Caption: problem
Caption: if you take this simple approach with
Caption: the formula on screen
Caption: if we want to add a new node or remove a
Caption: node
Caption: The Shard count in this formula changes
Caption: and what that means though is that
Caption: most of the keys now go to a different
Caption: Shard number it means your data needs to
Caption: be moved from many nodes to many other
Caption: nodes essentially you can't scale up or
Caption: down
Caption: way back in 1997 Akamai Technologies
Caption: invented consistent hashing
Caption: so what it does differently is that it
Caption: instead assigns each node in equal range
Caption: of that hash base and this is visualized
Caption: as being distributed around the outside
Caption: of a ring which is where the term hash
Caption: ring comes from
Caption: you can imagine that each node is inside
Caption: an equal piece of the pie
Caption: and the output of the hash function is
Caption: mapped onto the ring and this Maps it to
Caption: a node
Caption: the major advantage that this approach
Caption: has is that if a node is added or
Caption: removed then far less the data needs to
Caption: be moved between the nodes just the
Caption: overlapping sections of your ring
Caption: and this overhead is relatively low and
Caption: manageable
Caption: the process of moving this data around
Caption: is usually called rebalancing and this
Caption: is an important thing for a database to
Caption: do if it wants to allow scaling up or
Caption: down without rebuilding the database and
Caption: while data is being moved the DB might
Caption: need to reroute requests internally
Caption: until the rebalance is complete
Caption: in a distributed data system there's
Caption: often several copies of the data on
Caption: multiple nodes as well to guard against
Caption: losing one of them
Caption: this gives the benefit of redundancy but
Caption: plus higher availability should one of
Caption: the copies become unavailable
Caption: because this this also reduces the need
Caption: for Ultra expensive Reliable Hardware
Caption: because failures do happen anyway so if
Caption: they're embraced and handled this is a
Caption: win for reliability and cost
Caption: okay we've talked a bit about how data
Caption: is logically distributed
Caption: but how do the nodes actually know
Caption: what's going on elsewhere in the cluster
Caption: and what what makes them a team
Caption: they might need to know where a piece of
Caption: data belongs who's responsible for it
Caption: who else has a copy
Caption: other no other nodes healthy failing
Caption: shutdown there's been a node added or
Caption: removed how does it learn of all this
Caption: this needs to be shared and this can't
Caption: always be configured up front and never
Caption: change
Caption: so I'm going to talk about two
Caption: techniques that are used for this
Caption: if you can tolerate a slight delay
Caption: before all of your nodes are in sync say
Caption: less than 10 seconds
Caption: then a common approach is to use a
Caption: gossip protocol
Caption: a gossip protocol is sometimes also
Caption: called an epidemic protocol
Caption: because it's similar to the way that
Caption: epidemics spread
Caption: when a node receives a new piece of
Caption: Gossip it randomly picks one or more
Caption: other nodes to pass it onto
Caption: and this piece of Gossip spreads until
Caption: all of the nodes have it
Caption: this can happen surprisingly quickly and
Caption: large clusters can converge in seconds
Caption: why bother with this trouble though
Caption: can we just tell all of the other nodes
Caption: directly or maybe our Network supports a
Caption: broadcast
Caption: the problem with that is that it doesn't
Caption: scale very well as the number of nodes
Caption: increases the amount of network traffic
Caption: goes up exponentially until the system
Caption: collapses
Caption: so gossip protocol instead keeps the
Caption: overhead on the network and each node to
Caption: a pretty constant level even for very
Caption: large clusters you just sacrifice a
Caption: little time
Caption: but you might also think why can't they
Caption: just be a coordinator or a leader and
Caption: the nodes stay in sync with this leader
Caption: absolutely that works very well for
Caption: mostly smaller clusters and there are
Caption: plenty of distributed databases out
Caption: there that operate with this model
Caption: but we've introduced a weakness what
Caption: happens when the leader becomes
Caption: unavailable
Caption: the system can't share any new
Caption: information until that's resolved
Caption: okay let's make the coordinator
Caption: redundant have three of them but how do
Caption: they stay in perfect sync and how do
Caption: they decide on a leader so we've come up
Caption: against the problem of distributed
Caption: consensus
Caption: so one way to decide on something is to
Caption: have a simple vote
Caption: a simple majority is enough to decide on
Caption: the outcome but computers and networks
Caption: can fail at any moment and this can skew
Caption: the voting
Caption: it's pretty fundamental need to be sure
Caption: of what has happened in your system
Caption: in 1990 Leslie Lampert first wrote a
Caption: paper describing the paxos algorithm
Caption: which is the seminal work on distributed
Caption: consensus
Caption: but it turned out to be hard to
Caption: implement and hard to understand and
Caption: left a lot to be solved by developers so
Caption: much later in 2013 the raft algorithm
Caption: was published
Caption: it's based on paxos but but easier to
Caption: understand and to to work with and so
Caption: it's been popular since then
Caption: so consistency in a distributed system
Caption: needs Global agreement on changes but
Caption: how does it work if instead we chose to
Caption: give up strong consistency to be
Caption: available
Caption: we can't just let changes be lost can we
Caption: so instead practical systems are instead
Caption: what's called eventually consistent
Caption: this means that the different nodes in
Caption: this system asynchronously replicate
Caption: data to each other and then Converge on
Caption: one just just one value for any piece of
Caption: data
Caption: in the meantime it's sometimes possible
Caption: to read a value that's out of date
Caption: a new value is being written somewhere
Caption: else in the system but it's not yet
Caption: visible to me but if I wait it will
Caption: arrive
Caption: but how long is eventually of course the
Caption: answer is it depends it's milliseconds
Caption: or often seconds but it could be hours
Caption: when recovering from complex failures
Caption: there also needs to be a way to decide
Caption: how to convert these conflicting changes
Caption: into one result
Caption: the simplest approach is just last right
Caption: to wins and this is a common choice in
Caption: eventually consistent systems because
Caption: you just compare the timestamps and take
Caption: the latest one and discard the others
Caption: it's intuitive enough but for it to be
Caption: practical it depends on servers having
Caption: fairly synchronized clocks
Caption: algorithms exist to detect conflicts
Caption: like logical clocks or vector clocks but
Caption: they don't automatically resolve these
Caption: conflicts necessarily and so a lot of AP
Caption: systems decided not to use them
Caption: the reality is often never as simple as
Caption: a choice between these two opposites and
Caption: this is true of cap the CP versus AP
Caption: trade-off is more of a spectrum and
Caption: databases exist somewhere in there
Caption: a very important real world Factor
Caption: that's missing from cap theorem is L for
Caption: latency how of how quick it is to read
Caption: or write your data is often very
Caption: important
Caption: unfortunately there's a fundamental
Caption: trade-off between consistency
Caption: availability and latency
Caption: a big motivation for building these
Caption: database systems to begin with was scale
Caption: and performance
Caption: Amazon design Dynamo to serve its
Caption: shopping cart
Caption: Google built bigtable to serve and store
Caption: web search maps Etc Facebook built
Caption: Cassandra to power its inbox search
Caption: uh LinkedIn and Yahoo have similar
Caption: examples these systems needed
Caption: scalability and performance and this is
Caption: a big part of why they were AP systems
Caption: potential trade-off you make as we
Caption: discussed is the chance of reading
Caption: inconsistent data
Caption: this may be a non-issue when your data
Caption: doesn't change much these systems can be
Caption: a great fit for collecting mostly
Caption: immutable data like Telemetry events
Caption: messages
Caption: and they're also great for use cases
Caption: where you're okay with the occasional
Caption: glitch
Caption: and I'm sure that on the rare occasion
Caption: an item has just mysteriously
Caption: disappeared from someone's Amazon
Caption: shopping cart
Caption: has this hurt Amazon's reputation or
Caption: profits no
Caption: and not every business who made this
Caption: trade-off feels the same way though Uber
Caption: is one example but I'll talk about
Caption: trolling
Caption: after a while working with these
Caption: databases people were starting to
Caption: realize the cap theorem while
Caption: technically true and insightful wasn't
Caption: really nuanced enough for them
Caption: it's only an algorithmic property it
Caption: doesn't guarantee that AP systems are
Caption: actually up all the time
Caption: so the other other ways to think about
Caption: it
Caption: so Rick Houlihan introduced this tasty
Caption: concept called the pi theorem
Caption: you can choose two of these three
Caption: desirable properties of your data store
Caption: pattern flexibility infinite scale and
Caption: efficiency
Caption: and recall that the Iron Triangle of
Caption: purpose
Caption: so for some examples a relational
Caption: database is a PE system it's very
Caption: flexible to query it's usually quite
Caption: efficient but it definitely has a
Caption: scaling cap
Caption: a nosql database is an ie system
Caption: typically because it scales very well
Caption: it's got great efficiency but you can't
Caption: produce you can't do flexible queries
Caption: that you haven't planned for to begin
Caption: with
Caption: aquarable data Lake might be an IP
Caption: system huge scale low efficiency
Caption: so when you next need to choose a data
Caption: store you should consider this model as
Caption: well
Caption: in addition people some people learn the
Caption: hard way that eventually consistent
Caption: systems could be more trouble than their
Caption: worth for instance Google published this
Caption: and I'll paraphrase it's hard to build
Caption: bug-free systems when the database
Caption: doesn't guarantee consistency
Caption: the dynamodb offered by AWS has the
Caption: option of strong consistency within a
Caption: region azure's Cosmos DB has the option
Caption: of strong consistency Google's three
Caption: main databases for internal and external
Caption: use they all offer in some form of
Caption: consist strong consistency
Caption: some nosql data stores have since been
Caption: extended or even custom built
Caption: to support full asset transactions for
Caption: example Apple open source Foundation DB
Caption: which is a highly scalable nosql
Caption: database that supports full asset
Caption: transactions
Caption: and it Powers Apple's Cloud kit service
Caption: and snowflake uses it to store their
Caption: metadata
Caption: research continued in big Tech as well
Caption: as Academia and a new generation of
Caption: databases has emerged in the recent
Caption: decade and these have been dubbed new
Caption: SQL
Caption: it's a play or nosql but it represents
Caption: that they're a new generation of SQL
Caption: databases they can provide much higher
Caption: scalability and availability without
Caption: giving up the advantages of a relational
Caption: database
Caption: and this was seated Again by more papers
Caption: released by Google F1 and spanner
Caption: this was novel and it it inspired the
Caption: creation of a number of similar
Caption: databases
Caption: some of these are cockroachdb Thai DB
Caption: and gigabyte DB
Caption: so I mentioned a little startup you
Caption: might have heard of earlier Uber
Caption: Uber handles billions of transactions
Caption: per day now on their core order tracking
Caption: system if you've ordered an Uber or an
Caption: Uber Eats it's probably been through
Caption: there
Caption: and this was originally built on the
Caption: Cassandra database and they embraced
Caption: eventual consistency in this system in
Caption: order to get the scale they needed
Caption: however they were still frustrated by
Caption: occasional consistency problems and the
Caption: complexity of this added to their code
Caption: they've publicly talked about this and
Caption: how they're they've done a full rewrite
Caption: now to move to a consistent store
Caption: and they're using Google Cloud spanner
Caption: as the pro MDB
Caption: as more examples Netflix have blogged
Caption: about how they're making use of
Caption: cockroachdb
Caption: and we're using cockroach to be a family
Caption: Zone
Caption: this all sounds too complicated why
Caption: should I bother with the distributed
Caption: database
Caption: well if you don't have a need for high
Caption: scalability and high availability you
Caption: probably don't need one
Caption: however more and more apps find
Caption: themselves needing to handle bigger and
Caption: bigger data sets and sometimes sad that
Caption: the Common App is becoming a big data
Caption: app
Caption: the distributed databases that exist
Caption: today are the culmination of Decades of
Caption: research and development so you can have
Caption: your cake and eat it too with scalable
Caption: transactional databases that support SQL
Caption: and the relational model
Caption: and there are choices available out
Caption: there in addition to what's offered up
Caption: by your cloud provider
Caption: beware of giving up strong consistency
Caption: or at least be sure why you don't need
Caption: it before you give it up
Caption: if you need to work around the database
Caption: then perhaps it wasn't the ideal choice
Caption: for your problem
Caption: despite these these breakthroughs
Caption: there's still no one-size-fits-all
Caption: distributed database solution
Caption: there are generally purpose-built data
Caption: stores that might be ideal for your
Caption: particular workload perhaps an
Caption: analytical database was what you
Caption: actually needed or even a graph database
Caption: so do your research before you jump
Caption: and don't choose just based on the high
Caption: for the marketing
Caption: thank you for listening
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: do we have any time for questions are we
Caption: out
Caption: time for
Caption: one or two quick questions uh we are on
Caption: a time but yeah if there are questions
Caption: for Todd
Caption: sure
Caption: I think that's probably a lot of nuance
Caption: to that but
Caption: I think
Caption: if you're if your organization justifies
Caption: it so you have a big enough need
Caption: for using more than one database because
Caption: you need people that understand the
Caption: different Technologies you need to
Caption: maintain those different Technologies so
Caption: if you need the scale yes if you don't
Caption: need the scale that's where I'd consider
Caption: just making do with one but
Caption: absolutely if you
Caption: the point was that they're purpose built
Caption: so if if one suits your need very well
Caption: use it for that need
Caption: but you know that's easy to say and and
Caption: reality usually dictates that only if it
Caption: it's got the money behind it to justify
Caption: it
Caption: okay
Caption: thank you very much Todd uh we'll wrap
Caption: it there please give Todd another round
Caption: of applause and we'll move to our next
Caption: sessions
Caption: [Applause]